I've seen a bit of buzz online about
something called the Fineman technique
and how you can use it to improve your
grades
well the Fineman technique is
essentially the idea that if you can
explain a concept in simple language and
perhaps to someone else and answer their
questions about it then it's really good
practice for your own learning and
understanding
I think the technique is vaguely named
after richard fineman because this is
sort of an idea that he spoke about one
of his quotes is that if you can't
simply explain an idea then you probably
don't understand it well enough although
fine one would probably be surprised to
have this idea named specifically after
him because it is kind of a common-sense
idea anyone can sort of see that if
you're able to explain a concept that's
going to help you make sure you know it
yourself I don't think we need to be so
uptight about the exact steps to learn
through the Fineman technique but there
are definitely ways that we can
practically implement it into our own
learning one of them is simply just
talking to other people if you're a
student probably at university then just
talking to your peers and classmates
about the idea that you're learning try
to study with them is great because what
you can also ask your questions you can
answer theirs I don't think that as
students we should be shy of asking our
peers and friends questions on on how
something works or how to do a certain
part of an assignment because you might
feel guilty that you're taking up their
time and if it but really you are sort
of helping them as well as long as it's
not too over the top I think they would
appreciate putting into practice
explaining something they know
so I would say don't be shy to ask
people for help because it's going to
help the both of you another way you can
probably implement this technique is
just posting on forums whether it's
physics forums or any other type of
internet space there's always people
asking very intellectual or curious
questions about every topic and if you
think you're an expert in something or
you're studying to become an expert in
something go and check out some of the
relevant questions online and you may be
surprised to find some of the gaps and
your knowledge
I think answering questions on those
sites is really helpful it puts
knowledge out there to the world but it
also like I said helps you find out what
you don't understand I know I definitely
appreciate the people that post on those
kind of forums because they've helped me
many times in the past and I like to
think that they also gain some benefit
from answering these questions this
whole idea of explaining something
simply mimics a technique I've heard of
called rubber duck debugging which is
used
I think widely in coding circles because
what it is is essentially having a
little rubber duck or a toy or something
on your desk and when you've reached a
point in your task where you don't know
why it's not working you don't know why
your code seems to have a bug or why
something's going wrong instead of just
staring at the code for hours on end and
getting nowhere
you try to explain to the rubber duck
how the code works how every line of the
code is working and usually through
doing that you pick up on the mistake
yourself you realize that something in
there doesn't quite make logical sense
and it's a way to debug your own
programs it's all I think a similar idea
and like I said it's kind of common
sense
you don't really need a certain label to
this technique but I think it's good to
keep in mind that as well as always
trying to ask questions make sure you're
trying to answer them as well because
both of those components are going to
make you a really good learner and
someone that really understands what
they're trying to learn